you
let's make it a good one see how it goes
kick off in 15 two hours of three Oh
chess how's the scene in PA it's okay
all right
round one see we get alright this is
where I want to be right here
let me go there okay all right a Queens
gambit declined
going for tartakower
I believe clean side fiend keto or black
see five immediately know I'm going to
initiate this exchange
all right and
I'm going to take because I want to get
this move in at a moment where the Queen
isn't able to conveniently defend the
bishop I think this could be maybe a
little uncomfortable for black I'm
recalling some game I played maybe it
was against this same player I don't
know where this move could be a little
bit annoying
like if c5 was played instead of the
rook c8 move there's a knight move right
now that and the queen is defending the
bishop because of rook c8 instead of c5
it's not there
basically I have to take my queen can be
kicked away I don't know if I'm really
gonna grab that pot I may just fall back
if night before she can get trapped
of night before chop if here I could
sneak out along a diagonal no
it's close it's maybe a little bit too
scary okay I don't have a choice there
Queen takes a seven
this is a hard move to play but maybe
it's the right move to play
with one last night around I think I'm
that much closer to grabbing that pun
and yeah okay let's let's pull off a
faster move I've had a player play queen
a3 before stopping this I don't know
what you want to call it it feels like a
minority attack let's let's carry on I'm
getting rid of my isolated pawn Oh
that mouth
um let's go here
maybe here
okay
hmm
you
I just take that pond
let's go here preparing to me b5 with c4
rocks underdeveloped I actually have a
time edge
the c6 c6 is in there now how is this
not going to develop
huh
or what I like my night
hmm
you
what am i considering here
let's get a flight square in I don't
know something
I probably should have moved a little
bit faster there
all right they're gonna really push I'm
I'm unsure what I should be doing
REI is it this is bizarre
what I'm doing here I'm angling for be
Foursquare
they're gonna get a good square - yeah
and I don't like my position already
when the pond
okay this is not going well they're
going to try to win the pond now
the structure did not turn out how I
would like it on the queenside that's
for sure
not mind getting that pond
here to defend
my night may need to fall back here
yeah
let's go here okay I am in a complete
prevent what's what's stopping Queen
takes that movia Queen takes a five
33 seconds
ah wait I have enough defense
my rook is defended by my knight
here
it's not easy
it's not easy
you
okay can I get my knight here
time time time
any of it
you
take my night
you
Herman check
you
Oh crazy man crazy crazy crazy I am NOT
able to move fast
who is this I guess I'll try berserk
game this account somehow scares me
though
not as scared now I see these these
couple moves
can move fast I cannot move how it like
okay we should be crashing through here
see seven on the clean we got matin -
okay that was a quick three we're in
third stop the tournament get the podium
oh we're in fourth now Penguins in tenth
yeah right that's not gonna last long
okay
okay break up the center
that went that was very very bad how
that structure turned out
so
know what I'm doing here
like it's very easy play
let's go here I'm going to get off of
this this is not how you try to achieve
an advantage as white
okay that move what's the story behind
it
what is the story
you
my king may have to go here on a checkup
hey so I'm up upon how they getting this
guy back let's see
I still have some work to do my queen
side is
not the greatest alright let's let's
hold on tight to the e5 pawn
hey they're chipping away like that I
expected f6
I'm going to go here
because for the moment my night does a
good job of fighting off their night
okay so we go here we throw a punch and
maybe we get central soon central soon
huge square in the center my night was
just kicked to a better square I'm up
upon and my king is in a good spot
play here here and what stopping me from
playing here next can also just take
I think I like acquiring a connected
past pun
that's a little it's a little weird it's
a little weird my king being in the
center files maybe I just take
think I'm just going to take
let them gather up that pond a little
bit and I just want to get rook d1 and
then King f3 this is going to make B my
king's home I think
maybe King f1
okay
I mean could I try to cling onto this
pawn
not spend too much time here
I get to maintain my pawn there let's
see let's go for it
be greedy hang on all all the extra
pawns bishop here there's this
yeah
you
I really messed up didn't I
didn't I
I think my bishops gonna fall
Rover okay I got a bit too greedy there
I have a couple ponds that are far
advanced
you
hopeful that the f5 square is going to
be secure
right there holy cow
ah
man
yep ah man why I should've did it in a
much simpler way
you
you
I guess guard my pawns a little bit too
get here and here maybe
you
it's not even threatening though
commit when the bishop
down on the clock
you
and if I want to
Wow
I am just missing stuff that's felt so
natural to play that but I didn't play
it I might not find the natural stuff
I don't know how to untangle
and we try and push
Wow I'm in a giant pickle I can't get
out of this pin
and they're just able to simplify
that was horrible
it's an upsetting loss and in early one
in early upsetting loss
ah man
how could I have made it a little
simpler stop playing g4 and hanging on
to a second pun you dummy
ah that was ah that should not have been
[Music]
I got too greedy normally I'm okay with
just giving material back why was I not
okay with giving material back there
silly
silly silly silly
all right
maybe try and do something along the F
file
take once
all right
you
oh I'm giving my opponent
squares and everything
yep
that looks very good
you
this one's not going well
stop the knife from getting here but
yeah what about that move
this night is fantastic
I think that guy has to go
try here and here this is very very poor
play
poor play
you
you
it's not fun trying to be a defender
here
well let's go let's actually try and put
pressure on something huh knight on f6
try and reset
this is a half-dead pond
target its backward
that move
and see if I could
force white to go defensive for a move
exchange of rooks 92 I could put the
knight in a pin
here it's not stable hey they're just
going in for that move
yes we're gonna have a night ending
maybe maybe not it's up to white
yes a night
on board
take
and
guess I try to go hunting if I approach
there's this fork my night is not a
reliable defender of this he'd be kicked
so tough to get my king activated
I guess we land the checking up here so
now if ITIF I'm able to win this pond I
think I am now my knight defends here
but their King may get
oh that's helpful they had a blind spot
there
to the c6 square
okay let's go here
centralize the king first
take care
okay
you
you
you
go here
this one if I get to take with checks so
there's no sneaky way to get a pass or
four-way and I'll be able to improve my
king
not a fan I'm feeling very
I'm not feeling very confident in these
endings and why why why am I not I'm up
a night
guess we collect some ponds
you
okay they resigned where we at okay
barely any time to look the black eagle
I played e3 mistakenly
we could still try and make it work
though
maybe you should try something dangerous
something dangerous
I don't know
King in on this f5 square
I need to get castled soon open e-file
I continue to undermine
yes
no a five okay
three
you
so this space advantage is blocking in a
couple it's having an impact on a couple
minor pieces that clean up - are you
gone
my kingside she she not close to being
trapped
as well
reposition this bishop
only has one square can I take that one
away
how can I win that Quinn
you
night here
go in that light square bishop I don't
see
you
let's go with this
night chief or just this move
my queen defends up to
case there's any tricks Knight takes f2
all right
you
you
let's go here
is g3 close to trapping the Queen
setting up a night move with the
discovered check by
fens g3 also my bishop as well
at this coin I should be getting the
Queen for a minor piece very very soon
actually g3 and h4 and the queen is
cooked I don't have to move my night
now this
at these by the night in the bishop
all right Queen versus a
peace
to the seventh
all right we start taking some stuff
here
who's in a rout Oh seen this one before
you
all right my ponies aynd
where we at Naruto's in first 1683
rating
Wow
Wow
really
20-some minutes in
what's the overall standings right
let's keep going
break a pin keep your opponent in a pen
I could have considered this capture a
little sooner actually
Queen Bishop on Queen there to defend
it's going to clean here here is losing
because of chop-chop in my bishop hangs
so give them a little boot
sticking around
as here
here actually I don't know if I want to
back up now this is my bishop they're
like if night be five Queen b8 let's
let's see if we could do something about
this
and this
mass exchanges net upon
chop
chop and we take one pause here and say
my upon is more valuable than this half
dead see pum he's not going anywhere
so Queen takes e3 next
on and I think
maybe a third they have the pressure
alright the King needs to play a little
bit I could have grabbed h3
I'm proved the king of hair this is as
far as my king can go I guess we know
think about
pinpointing a different pawn
this rook is stuck
I can now improve my
further
further it's gonna be hit with the check
let's come over here
get this pawn up here in this pawn here
and then this guy is completely frozen
the a pawn cannot move
once I have before secure okay I could
come back over here with my king and mop
up this pond so now they should just all
fall
okay my pony resigned uh
an hour 35 to go still current standings
in eighth
all right let's go a t4 piece went a
little smooth this time
Carol come
alright let's just break the pin and I'm
open for an ending let's see
you
let's go here and then Knight to d2
with the rook I don't want a castle is
the thing
II - is a cozy home light square no
light square around no open e-file no
reason to throw the King to the edge
that's a demotion an unnecessary
demotion
how do we move forward maybe we could
try to sneak into this square huh
acquired some space
inevitable at this stage that an
additional minor piece comes off maybe
even two we may enter an ending where I
have some court grip King and pawn
ending
okay now this night maybe constructs I
have this
here
okay has d5 as well hang on hang on hang
on
you
you
I think I may try to cement
night into this square
this move and then this move
or
I think the order is important
maybe here first
and
only after the night goes here to
challenge my I to I go here he's going
to get this square though
now if this move
yeah okay they're looking at
that they're looking at doing that let's
go here can always go like this
hey I'm actually threatening to take
this pawn now okay I think they missed
that get to win a pawn
takes tonight I take here
all right once they were
okay my not winning some more material
soon this is a big threat winning upon
and then a full rook he just resigned
yeah a little tactic oh there the
overall standings aware where's the
overall standings tab I don't know I
only get to see when there's two seconds
after each game I can't I'm not sure
here we are at the team
and currently ninth for the team but
where's that overall stuff we don't know
all right
[Music]
weaken this but I stopped some expansion
on the queenside okay I think a five is
a serious consideration there
I guess sneaked in a flight square
very fast whereas my queen wannabe may
be here this can open up so I'm kind of
scared to go to e2 I hit with this move
or don't maybe go here they're not
threatening me five let's build up
let's go opposite their queen and see
how they feel okay still don't have
enough support for that should I go here
No let's back off chop here wouldn't
mind entering a
a minor piece of peace position
LightSquared bishop ending
okay because I have the slightly better
bishop to watch out for 9c2
we'll build up
push now the time to push let's go here
first centralize I could think about
night here I probably should have played
night there all right
let's just be annoying for a second I
think the queen has to go here will
repeat see how many seconds I can shave
off of a black's clock okay there see
how much was accomplished with those
last two moves
amazing amazing clockwork right there
okay that night continues to jump around
alright let's push see what happens
crack it open the center
rumble I think so I can't be better
centralized can I
I got enough coverage for this guy see
what happens an accident on f7 maybe
Oh sweeping in okay we got another check
here check the checks
go to check
where's the mate King here maybe I go
here or here looking for made on that
square this Knights pinned okay that's
just okay but my nights hanging - okay
let's take here we got a night for
yes okay here the standings here the
standings the top players are right here
the giant the chest giant a berserk game
oh I missed my chance for berserk game
you
all righty
it's flying
you
is that Queen stable she's not a
reliable defender of d6
okay okay we're three okay we got
another fast pairing here first time
playing this guy from
turkmenistan ice okay
let's go
let's go with this I don't want to
castle yet I'm dreams of launching a
jeep on let's do it
Jeep on is gonna be launched three two
one after a night move ninth c5 already
taking the steps to secure that night on
the c5 post so there we go
this is the all-in move
I'm saying no I'm not castling kingside
trying to discourage f5 and at the same
time not be afraid if f5 is in a square
knot for the bishop I have played this
position before I've had
I have also played this position before
where I actually give up this bishop for
the knight is odd as that may seem this
is my better Bishop but and you have
ideas in mind we may see these ideas
surface start with Queen here played a3
I know I give up this square
but I do not want to see this pond be
established on a three so okay first
things first let's take with the Jeep on
open up the G file and next
next I guess we castle
chop here and then this
now I don't like this idea of them
converging I guess I'm just gonna Castle
you're very delicate right now it's a
night move with check my night has to
probably watch over B for B 3 if if he
gets into B 3 he's getting into d 4
which is the most
oh the week is square in my camp let's
let's scoot over here on b1 they're
getting off of the open G file chopper
owning so
maybe here
you
that's been too much time yeah I'll give
it a go
don't move Knight something bad
up and fast they want to go here if they
give me a chance Rick b3 is a candidate
move
yepper
am I even threatening to take that rook
let's let's maybe
maybe giving up my clean for a rockin
pawn
that may be happening soon
let's see if my Knights could be
coordinated well enough in this
imbalance
gonna go for it or not
yea or nay they don't have to do it
right now me Knight to f6
yeah they've given up on that idea but
maybe now I could scare the rook away go
here
release some pressure on the B file and
get the my knight back here so this is a
moment key moment to unleash the bishop
yes or no no I think I'm better now
I didn't say I'm losing that pond
let's go here
so want to make sure their bishop is
shut out
okay
I want to keep some pieces on I have the
safer King
let's go here if you take I get to the
seventh time time time
it's hanging under their pond
you
clean over I really want to get that
poem
no past a pond I forgot I could do that
Queen exchange is my Punk can my palm be
cut
you
now if it's a draw Oh
it's going to be a time scramble
I coulda grabbed my bishop
ah
I wish I recognized this a this a pond
past a pond idea a bit sooner
could have maybe set it set it up a bit
more precisely where my apon couldn't be
caught by their king I had it in my mind
that my king that my queen wanted to
take their pawn on a4 but I didn't want
to allow activity
on the queenside
well of course that was a draw
objectively got the W on the clock
and I guess I'm miss playing this
okay I guess c4 is toast see if I could
start no they don't want c4
go here 96 I can play 95 they try to do
something dangerous against my king
there's no Bishop takes h2 it's check as
a way out
let's go here
you know really be okay with giving up
the bishop for a night shouldn't be
alright this seems good right to see one
there might be Night Moves soon
you
the rook mu was careless
yeah bit careless there
instead of rook c1 I should have played
f4 with than this okay they're looking
to kill me
you
back on the clock here
I don't know let's do something here
let's keep going
and add something to bite out
c6 is it
all right I play here this guy's hit a
million times
two nights bish up clean now
scary got a lot of pieces pointing at my
king
here here style gets weakened
the clock
faster
hmm
mega day six as soon as there is a night
on c5
nine of four
tricks here with Czech huh
you
let's see
I may not even take I just I'm
kingi one if they play night there
this is definitely move if they have
control over Jiwon I'd be getting mated
so I'd have to take okay the night just
jumps in there I could get the Queen's
off No
let's go here
you
and here
you
you
let's go here remember be able to back
off I think
on exchange Queens maybe 95
o'night there boof inside I wanna
you
yeah they're on my clean
alright let's grab a pond
pieces are very unstable
moment night they may miss that
from my night though
let's take
very uncoordinated
I missed like a block here
poof sixteen seconds
you
skitter Rockoff can I get a rock off
you
ah
get my clean right back
you
got to go got to go
and fast
let's go night do something dangerous
please
you
hop around
you
you
whoo only one second in the tank whoo
let's try f4
I can't go I can't go
as I was like as I would like it's just
always slow when I stream
okay let's soften up the queenside a
little bit
and try to get in here with what move
lay here first
women here
be a bit careful about this push because
of a
a skewer in the end
the night is not there let's see if I
could maybe see the smell first
no no that's interesting
let's run it like this let's fiend keto
we're not committing yet I'd love to see
this transformation this is there's not
enough support for you
I still don't think there's enough
support for C form
you
mmm
let's get a little wild here
Jeep on put the fear in the night
g3 sensitive
King h2
no big deal they may still play this
puts double the extra pawn is not a
great pun
huh
I'm gonna go for this move
it's my queen
I want c4 for my night
normally I would look to immediately
improve this second-ranked night but not
here this is a juicy square c4 juicy
all right let's go back did your job
recapturing Queen
at one way or another the night let's
see let's jump in
I think I want to take away from the
center as otherwise this is a nice pawn
break
all night here night night would hit
that with tempo
all right
I guess we sneak in here
with the king
you
you
I don't know pick a move I should have
went with the other up maybe a six if
the Queen does something I should have
been too quick to to leave that a pawn
yeah
all right well I'm not going back to
babysit it going all in we're gonna try
to attack here scare the night away
doesn't have too many squares yeah
step up with the king yeah he's a
fighter Queen f3
so much for the attack or well maybe the
attack is still there huh because what
about this what about it
about this move
what about that
not just winning a piece
the exchange
if here the night would have dropped
into e4 I'm also on the night consider
taking it up taking the night in
breaking up the kingside
all right so they're just I never think
I want to kick the night first
tonight is worth a look now
I feel like there should be mates
take the material let's go
oh I missed that move
know that night's going to be so strong
you
being so sneaky
oof
you
you
this has gotten away from me for sure
you
you
Wow they're allowing that
you
you
who allow me to get here
you
you
now time whoo I should never have
allowed that night to get to f5
that night was beastly hmm
okay submarine
submarine
let's go with d5 again submarine
all right
hmm I'll hang on to my bishop no no
Knight H for hunting
okay the Queen's off
this is bad for me right don't want
those guys to be undone this is this is
bad for me I don't know why I keep
playing the same same variation
this is so bad
let's play with g5 I'm trying to
discourage this bishop from getting on
this diagonal just stop it
also my kitty like if if I don't have to
worry about the bishop getting here
maybe my King could be a reliable
defender to this kind of attack
okay
to do about e4 happening
you
okay maybe maybe I act in the center
yeah even if even if like if they take
like this at some point in their up upon
at least it's obstructing this bishop
one way or another let's see
as a very fuzzy explanation but
all right checking to see if I'm just
still alive Here I am
you
in the tank submarine is in the tank
if for this I'm prepared to back off
okay
whoa totally miss that move
I was expecting e4
okay I am going to lose maybe
Wow
didn't see that one
all right let's play like this I think
this is maybe one of the better ways to
try and keep things closed now that I'm
down a piece of full piece
ah
and I can't take that
I don't know I'm in trouble
losing
you
yeah
to just pry it open
you
you
my night is a big big dummy
I'm just blind to any idea White has in
this game
wasn't noting that the night has
pressure there
you
mm-hmm
you
let's go King
somehow still alive
you
sooo not anymore
not anymore
you
yeah I could safely resign right 22
seconds is too much f4 was a nice shot
totally missed F for losing a piece
maybe I could have salvaged a pond or
something for the piece I don't know
it's totally blind out for but actually
before I even get in that I shouldn't be
in that position to begin with I go down
that path far too many times and it's
just bad bad bad that play along the a
file that little Knight maneuver towards
the queenside I shouldn't be in that
environment to begin with so
all right
don't guarantee that I get this pawn
back
before is in there
after I Castle I'm threatening that pun
okay
and if I go here this may start to look
dangerous
perlite the night cannot move for the
moment okay
you
now let's keep the pin
okay they're out of the pin but
but but but they have compromised their
kingside they don't have a LightSquared
Bishop Brown and there are two big
weaknesses
keep the Queens on no need to double or
double up my pawns like this and now can
we try a five and have my bishop
crunched
huh
you
you
um I want to do this
not sure
you
[Music]
all right let's let's do something with
my bishop maybe
still keeping open this h5 idea
I don't know let's try something on the
Queen's our King side here
all right I probably just could have
captured their let's try this
you
you
Oh wine I take care
I think that I could adjust
there one move sooner get my bishop here
and then mate here I don't see how I
pull that off though secure my pawn is
past
cut the square covered Oh
alright let's just win that pom if both
of these are not here watching over e -
I could play Bishop b2 to f3 so as soon
as one of them gets overly excited like
that guy I could slip on in here and
their mate should be nearby
yeah
I think I could afford to
you
let's be a little sneaky actually this
move rook takes pawn rook a1
because
Queen h3 will next be threatening to to
fermions
and the check isn't anything same story
of this chop-chop clean h3 no way to
stop both queen g2 and queen h1
you
no good solution here
don't think not to move Dupree move that
could go here
do this now though the queen is pinned
I got me okay light-square weaknesses
that queenside I think Knight takes a
five they could have gotten away with
this okay we are in eighth Zipit videos
long time no play
against exhibit videos
a Benoni
let's go
check our Oni and this because I don't
want to see a quick clean side expansion
all the way back I don't want to see
night there with tempo
all right Knight h5 know I thought
Knight h5 was maybe the way
you
we're not age five now that I have my 92
already
sneak in a flight square
you
let's go here
oh they going for that maneuver that's a
thing yep
all righty
let's back off secure this and I'm
looking for a night dance I just want to
dance a little bit in my night here
you
stuff let's improve my bishop first I
want to exchange this guy off might
let's give it a shot and take with the
pawn I'm going to keep this ID up
[Music]
let's go right in for this it's kind of
thinking about g3 but that's I don't
know that's kind of weird yeah
okay night there
should probably still angle for this
square and a push
you
very good control over this square
here with this expecting
maybe hint at this uh this post that be
night here Queen here and then f3
yeah that move is coming
I just want the square more than
anything
all right
it's a little scary
hmm
you
I don't know
you
this is almost certainly wrong what I'm
doing
and I here in love for Queenie five
yeah
you
you
yeah they should just recapture I think
the check I think is maybe incorrect
maybe tempting but incorrect
now that works
because they get this
have to play here
I've just made it into Kawena four and
then
except to
nice near that F
six move actually before the f6 move it
was bad for me I keep forgetting about
this ID to play g5 and then coordinate
all minor pieces on the e5 square hmm
well played
already
you
you
let's go here
you
one minor piece off some space is it an
advantage
once more Benoni
let's see if I could do better with this
benoni
you
all right let's go a g4 can I now take
that pond let's try it
um can I not take this pun let's try
that - what am I missing
get out
please
trade
you
okay
you
you
here prepared to kick the kind of go at
g5
you
let's see let's get this structure in
there
two extra ponds
take with the bishop or the pawn
take at the pond I guess
okay they're just sacrificing and it
take
clean takes here
I like my bishop on this square try get
some material off soon
King feels a little bit more cozy in
this square
first up a full night
alright time to trade
a little bit
you
you
[Music]
do not like how I'm playing
you
took me too long it's thinking I could
only recapture it's my queen I didn't
want to drop B - who here knows more
stuff
alright let's focus here huh
upon
with the king very very poor technique
so far
yep
change of the guard
you
here how about this can we move that
night is going to be swiped
you
on the Queen and the bishop
all right
you
all right
I'm out of material
brother
brother
you
I don't know Adam mate with two bishops
this is a weird ending my bishops are
beasts
you
should've played here
you
you
you
I'm not playing well oh man
but you won that game no no no no no no
nope nope nope nope nope
technique atrocious to pick to be up a
piece like that and yeah just not not my
day
nope
oh man oh man
take with the queen the night loves this
square and be a manoeuvre I like getting
this move in if we can
all right what's the
I am
in that guy aboot let's try it
you
take take Queen exchange Queen exchange
it is okay how to assess this ending
I think all things normally should start
with that
and then it's like king improvement I
also thought about this move myself
mm-hmm
all right need to keep one rock on
they continue to cement my pawns on
light squares
all right let's see if we could be a
pest
you
getting outplayed
why am i letting all my pawns be
cemented on light squares
that's a bit of a surprise
you
let's go here
you
put all my pawns on light squares that's
the big plan
you
you
trying to create some target on the
queenside
you
of this square open its the thing
feels a little weird
you
get my king back I want to hide
and may go in for that
and go in for that or not otherwise it's
pretty clean I think that to muddy the
waters
should be pretty clean my King position
is really strong winning this guy too
you
can't take that pawn ooh I took the pawn
skewer town god I'll played in that one
I was very very lucky very very lucky
with that one
I should have played that c5 move much
much sooner well I didn't play it at all
am I talking about sooner yeah they
started fixing all my pawns on light
squares my bishop was not happy about
that
nada
okay see if we could be a maneuver
you
let's go here
so hole
um take what the night
you
you
keep going for your dance here night a
six into this sweet spot on on b5
noted you get a square I get a square
let's see Queen on e2
I want my knight on c4
ecigs or f5
there's nothing fancy here just yet my
rook is unprotected
East 6rf five other
I think I can slowly find ways to
improve
better than black can
you
already
let's play here right away
I'm actually considering something
unusual
B takes c4
dropping my clean back home
let's go it this is the thing is as soon
as this night moves let's create a
square for my king so as this night
moves if we have this room I drop a rook
in to b5 I'm going to try it
it's very unusual
now this and this is almost like an
instant move but I also don't want a
backward pause so this night sits on a
good square
but
to what
maybe up three if they try a queen
exchange now that g3 is covered okay so
they're playing in the center but now
there's something to bite at so let's
get here
and restrict to one of the majors okay
you
take like this I don't want them
have this guy runnin it'd be too
dangerous
all right and let's go here watch over
these forward moves by the knight here
and then here and then here
think I want one rock off
one raka what about two rocks off
you
could take here and defend this pawn
her to exchange Rex and play Queen f4
it's going to be a night end game soon
and the tank
these six is my focal point
okay I should have something here
stay with us
threatening this and then here back rank
stuff on a che
same story here
threatening to just win the queen or the
king now
and we could do it like this
jump around a little bit
discoveries and stuff okay back to
tournament land we're in eighth I
haven't been mentioning it 36 to go in
63rd overall Zapp is having a fantastic
tournament 48 with fire very nice messy
answer I see there as well cam bod who's
been participating in many of the Swiss
tournaments I've created
very nice
yeah one of our games was very very
tense
myself in cambot
okay let's let's prep Annie for move
you
all right let's castle missing any
tricks
I don't think so
all right now now let's go for this
capture and a push it's getting tense in
the center now eventually I think they
should be capturing here and I'm like
having that clean restricted I was also
threatening a fork
you
and see how it changes
okay
'if I've
you
somebody trying for a battery here is
easily defended by night on f8 so if I
try to kick on it's no big deal it's
very solid on their King side should I
be trying something else over here don't
want to capture the rook is brought to
life
b5 with this kind of stuff I don't know
'if I've with the night dance well let's
try that let's try a five and maneuver
my night maybe here or here here night
h9h 2 into G 4 maybe maybe then there's
a sacrifice soon Queen c7 I have to come
back
and some support there okay clean b6r
actually I like this much better come to
think of it night on G 3 and H 5 and
also this is a battering ram with G 5 on
this move I think here
on this move I could play here without
fear of this because I
checking to win the Queen also that's
probably poison in other lines with the
simple skewer work on the B file
guess the light-square bishop is going
to be exchanged soon start with this so
that way this move cannot be met with h5
let's carry on with this I guess I have
to take like that okay miscalculated and
realize this is unprotected but okay
we'll see
yeah that move
you
okay but if I take here
okay Knight f6 yeah
you
they're nights cover a lot of squares
man
I was just I wanna okay let's get over
here
Queen h4 and then okay the night on
night on g6 my queen their nights are
very good defenders I need to get in
Knight h5 not giving me any time for
that
hmm we have to give up on any kind
tack
yeah I don't think I have anything
definitely worse
definitely worse
yeah night enough for I guess maybe a
sacrifice here
bunch of pawns for a night three
hopefully
you
guarding d3
why they'd given me that outside passer
a little odd oh they're taking first
here
and here maybe we start pushing I think
I'm ready to sacrifice night 1/2 night
there
let's let's go here a little patient
how much time
and they're just getting the pawn right
back it's that easy and now we sacrifice
at an even worse moment
you
I am time time
this one
Oh get this guy
wait oh I thought that I had made or
something I don't have any time the
attack was long off no attack on the
kingside they defended that really well
their queen
they're nice were well positioned to
defend my knight any knight moves
53rd overall
right now zap is in there 52i 51 49 46
top players for the team sincerity rules
I see you there
and at 11th
let's keep on going
you
Oh
it's kind with a four they're ready to
take this guy out and expand
all right
reckon Siwon I think the Queen could
feel uncomfortable soon
especially since she's in a pin however
indirect and also she has a
responsibility that's a huge move Wow
so if I take here first what's going on
let's find out no fork yet
file to be opened up clear of any white
pawns one step closer now to maybe doing
something against the Queen also Knight
takes Knight takes Bishop takes I could
then think about this move okay so
they're taking once more I don't think
there's any benefit in me
capturing on d6 I'm just inviting the
Queen off of the pin and to ask where
where she applies pressure to d5
all right hitting my queen all right
suppose now in this position I play here
does this maybe make life a little bit
difficult for black to take on d5
because of my pressure on h7 so let's
take here
so I'm currently up upon they stuffed a
stop to get that guy back here here my
nights unprotected okay so they are
allowing Bishop takes h7 I think I
should take it and then immediately free
up my queen they're going there
maybe take the night first yeah I
actually like taking the night getting
one less piece
piece off the board an additional piece
off the board and now maybe this and the
Queen sweeping in will make black think
twice possibly about that decision to go
towards the center for my queen is on h7
that could be super disruptive I'm also
threatening to simply take the knight
and maybe win this c5 pawn no
think so
I'm not concerned at all if they I
prefer to have this pawn on f3 instead
of g2 because there's a nice pocket for
my king it just win another pawn
in between move to consider that
it's actually Oh No okay
oh here hit some more stuff it's
important that if pawn takes pawn Queen
takes pawn is coming with check is
otherwise there's this move
Queen takes a six now let's try and keep
it simple also with an eye on the clock
yep
here
I see you take B I take
my rook is ideally placed here they're
taking out the night we're gonna pile up
on up to okay this is looking like a
draw
oh my goodness my opponent moved
I didn't see that they moved
I should have move my rook
you
put my rook on f3
still trying here to rooks is still
tactical
if I can look forward to f5 break ooh
America's frozen
G for break now five I want to get an f5
King here I get a nap five
whoa Oh Mouse alípio
over and over it's not over
[Music]
you
okay another hook
at the king of and move these gays
no stalemates Wow
you're an 8 stuck at 8 9 24 okay FC
Rostov Chinese for a game 23 minutes to
go I'll try the Scandinavian they're
going to Scandinavian I'm playing this
oddball looking oh let's go for this
actually
disrupter pawn sacrifice
they're asking for trouble tonight on c4
stabilize my
say who cares if you kick them
it's very weakening to the king I'm
angling for this e5 square
yeah we got a fork coming up so no
it's castle surprise they went with that
night I'm being honest because this one
is crying out to be kicked soften up the
kingside all right
go here see how comfortable that King
feels
not very
rook here was probably better stopping
clean here just preparing to double they
have a lot of weekend squares
here probably this I could have
considered sooner
this is a threat
this is broken
let's grab a poem
you
I'm all the way back this is back on
it's hitting even harder now
let's go to a safe Square
let's get a flight square night's still
in a pin although rook a four
you
I want to take and then do something
here in case they take take back with
the pawn
you
they just resigned I thought they were
going to at least try to run
their king all right
zap is in there with 60i 59 59 54
Matthew gee this guy is always up there
yeah there he is he's in number two spot
he always finishes
in an awesome spot
let's go here focus on some squares yeah
should I just dive in
you
now
let's just come back actually
the pond No
you
but at least some halt to this b4 idea
you
hm
you
let's keep going with this
see if I get the H file opened up
maybe that I'm not sure which is better
let's let's keep that option open for a
moment
yeah
seems odd but I'm going to do it
dreams of this
here here
yeah I see they have squares as well
let's open it up prepared to dive in
let's get back here control the night
like to get these moves in night h4 if
my night is kicked as well
I'm gonna take like this and get a
pastor it's very dynamic now very very
dynamic
it's portion
oh here I go here then I get this pone
no I go in for that in-betweener get
this pawn now
they're ready to dive in with check
I'd have to take that night
right
mm-hm
yeah
here
very sharp they're clean fortunately is
out of play or is she
ship here was maybe missed
no rugby one Oh
open upon booth
that was a big pun
you
from this square
you
wonderful time
have made up the clock time
you
I'm going to try it
Oh had cleaned there
you
Oh
if anything over here
oh my cleans hanging
I'm busted
who
I'm gonna clean oh and that's me oh that
got so sharp
I shouldn't have given up my I didn't
give it up I shouldn't have blundered my
a bond
was rough
I could tell they've they've played that
structure many times how quickly they've
rattled off those opening moves
okay okay okay
you
I want to get that one
hmm I don't care if the knight takes
there
okay they were threatening to take here
and then land a fork
take with the pawn if they if they take
my bishop or if they take my knight I'll
take with the poem
let's keep going
you
you
Knight takes
I wasn't expecting night takes
I think I should be able to get that
pawn back
right there
on h7
looking to also pin the night
offering a drone
you
take the night and then take on d4 and
try like this
hopefully I could get all of these
all right it's a broken ending rook and
pawn ending coming up first things first
stop that pond from going any further
yeah and now start with this guy I don't
want to see too many pawns exchanged I
don't want to see this rook challenged
either and now I think I could make some
slow steady progress
okay they're trying to trade again
let's go on this running like this
these guys going another
for nope
try man still trying
you're tied down and I'm not so I'm
gonna play
I just dropped this pawn
oops
now I'm in trouble
now I should be the one asking for a
draw oh man now I gotta go into pre boo
mm I might be getting made
ah man I might my rook was on the wrong
rank
I was thinking he was defending that
pawn before I made that pawn advance
maybe you should have played oh now I am
getting mated yeah they have a pawn push
oh I get to take in his wits check hang
on
lining that up though it is very close
Rokoff
ah that was going to be a fun
to play I think
here and then here
I'm lucky I'm able to take wits check
otherwise one of the Eicher f-pawn
combined with these two rooks I think
would be able to weave a mate
you
now let's go here I'd like to have one
Rockoff still a little scary
you
you
perpetual attack against the rook to get
one ruck off their long time and maybe
we play for time
maybe
I don't want both rocks off I'm losing
look there - there
you
I can't move
you
oh my goodness oh we're not time a win
on time lost on position
eight minutes in change remaining
okay one
game will count for the tournament
and
maybe you'd get one more in there just
for the fun of it is green arrow going
to move yes
right green arrow on at the knight c3
turns into a French
okay
huh let's go here
Wow
I forgot that that was a little huh
well this is already poorly played what
I'm doing here
we're going queenside
gonna take care
yeah your name alright let's let's
circle in maybe we do something
dangerous
over here
play with this move
I didn't calculate that I could get the
night after before right away
Wow
you
9 on c4 okay
that move nice I go here
chop-chop that's a big pun night is
pinned up upon
get a second one maybe sweep in here and
get a second poem now line up
could have also considered that which
was maybe
pop
let's go here without fear of Queen
takes pawn check and I get the clean I'm
the d3 square I didn't see that move
no I definitely didn't see that move
and I could take here though
here rook takes and then the check
I think that's fine like this
let's pause for a second
let's move and hit something that's on
tech to defend this as well
there
put the bishop in a pin
let's try this
it's not quite enough no it's not quite
up in
so I go here
we're not just winning
at this check if they can
here queen is currently tied down if
this I go here here and then here it's a
big square and d1 if we got this so we
go for a check
for another check that's it all right I
won't actually finish pretty fast so
we're going to get one more game in
possibly with five minutes to go
ah the wild trickster let's try e4
against the wild trickster maybe a a
wrong first start against a player like
this
try and exchange irui
all right no they're going with
something different here so
I'm not sure what this this opening is
this variation is
you
that's a no huh
I guess so
you
save the bishop prepared to run they
have already equalized I'm pretty sure
I take with the night because I want to
kick this guy
let's go here
theft if they have to play off six I'm
I'm happy I may actually win upon have
six check King in the corner exchange
Queens and then I take twice here so
they got to move the Queen there which
isn't secure
let's give her a boot
okay she's found safe ground
here
there should be six I think is the way
Bishop e6 Bishop c4 maybe
the night is strong an f5 Bishop e6 I
think is best yeah
I'm going to say let's keep the cleans
on defend this
I think this [ __ ] is pretty irritating
also night c-5 as possible
try and rattle this strong bishop post I
have this one under control I believe
the dark square bishop because of this
structure but these two stand very well
all right also the queen is now watching
over f6
maybe
to challenge their strong night
you know it's let's go here I was
thinking they had this move for a second
or two
now this guy is a pest and my bishop is
unprotected maybe
let's go here here I got killed
fish up they're hitting this square
defend
yeah that's
I gotta go hear both of these are
hanging it's not fun
as here
back off
well both of my bishops back
we can take maybe I now queen takes
there is probably too much
too much of a pawn grab
for the tournament
like Wayne just I guess we'll try that
you
you
we like a sacrifice here maybe nearby
even on the clock
and there
folks we have tactics onboard
you
hmm
I'm going to take the rook if Ricky too
my bishops in a pin
right there might be a move
yeah
that my oh they could take first with
check
ah
you
a nice try to coordinate
you
you
not this move
allowing me to get something here it's
not easy actually
I'm coordinated
Queen takes bishop
I'm in a pen
you
check
you
you
huh I'll they're down on time Oh a man
it's very clunky the end with that Mouse
okay that is a battle all right I don't
even know how everybody ended up doing I
didn't see any like overall stats whoo
tough event we finished eight very nice
time we were 9 out of 10 634 were in
there let's see the final well first of
all who won fiona's Fight Club 1 penguin
came in second
and then Chris book chess club top three
chagall Co YouTube twitch their chests
TV the arab team Eric Rosen fan club
just Network GAD mater's team chess 24
turkey
we finished 57th overall
alright let's actually see
let's see who finished where for the
team let's see the top 50
I had 63 Shama Canal
thank you for playing for the team you
finished with 63 as well very nice
result Zapp Branigan 62 sincerity rules
62
5957 and you could see the whole list a
player had a very good result
fifty-four top 20
and these guys all up and that is our
total right there 1090 let's see the top
50
top 50 right here if you can't see the
last one cipro SIF ro
finishing in 50th for the team thank you
all for competing let's go through
through the top
top of 100
years see who finished what Matthew G
the one who berserk me to victory
finishing with 99 listen three normally
players over a hundred for these battles
huh
no not an all-out berserk but yeah
pretty close to it 83% finishing first
Matthew G awesome 99 penguin there 98
opera 96 Hans 94 and you could see them
all GM's AIIMS and FM taking it 5990 in
there let's see the top 100 so there's
page 2
Age 3
you
I wasn't even noting the teams that I
was playing against like the
representatives over what team
there am 5750 seventh place
Schama canal finishing 61st overall
Zapp Branigan 74 sincerity rules 76
overall
and that's going to do it top 100
some event
I wish there was a way you could see the
standings up like while you're playing
that's still not a thing it games all
only aware of the team standings but not
though overall
battle as it's taken place all right fun
event as usual
you